for years and years I've been
researching blockchain technology
cryptocurrencies the market booms and
busts and many have asked me to explain
Bitcoin to them and they really could
compete with if not even take down the
Facebooks and the Googles and the
Amazons my name is Torsten Hoffman and
I'm going to put some of these claims to
the test some critics say you kind of
hurt the community what's your response
to that this innovation has enabled a
lot of criminals and scammers
but basically looking at it now you you
lie to us
cryptocurrencies everything you don't
understand about money combined with
everything you don't understand about
computers